ich begrüße sie wieder recht herzlich
ein pressebriefing zum pressebriefing im
robert-koch-institut heute ist
donnerstag der dreißigste april
wir sind hier heute einen tag vorher
sonst sind wir ja freitags quasi auf
sendung aber morgens feiertag und
begrüßen auch wieder professor wie der
präsident des robert koch-instituts der
das statement abgeben wird guten morgen
meine damen und herren lassen nämlich
beginnen mit meinem wiederholten appell
an sie und an uns alle dass wir weiter
hier durchhalten und dieses virus in
schach halten in unserem land das uns
ganz gut gelungen ist in den letzten
wochen
bitte bleiben sie weiter wann immer es
geht zu hause halten sie die kontakt
beschränkungen ein wichtiger punkt dem
virus keine chance zu geben
übertragen zu werden halten sie weiter
abstand mindestens anderthalb meter ist
unsere empfehlung waschen sie sich
regelmäßig und gut die hände halten sich
an die husten und niesen und wenn sie in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln unterwegs
sind oder zum beispiel ein geschäft wo
sie nicht garantieren können dass sie
diese abstände einhalten können bitte
tragen sie zusätzlich zu den maßnahmen
einen mund nasen bedeckung und zwar um
andere zu schützen das ist wichtig und
es wird uns so gelingen wenn wir das
weiter durchhalten dass wir die
fallzahlen auch weiter drücken können
und bislang ist uns das gut gelungen das
ist sehr gut und das wollen wir weiter
zusammen so durchhalten dann können wir
dieses virus in schach halten nun
zunächst ein blick auf die
internationale situation wir vergleichen
kurz den stand deutschland der ist vom
30 04 00 uhr mit dem stand im ausland
gehen wir wie immer einen tag früher
sehen also 10 uhr 29 der fürther die
ganzen zahlen die ich ihnen kurz
vermeldet sind gerundet aber sie geben
einen schönen einblick in die dynamik
die wir welt
haben vereinigte staaten nun inzwischen
mehr als eine millionen gemeldete fälle
dort und darunter haben wir 58 1400
todesfälle zu beklagen
das ist ein anteil der verstorbenen von
den offiziell gemeldeten in den
vereinigten staaten von 5,8 prozent
schauen wir nach europa spanien 210 1800
fälle offiziell gemeldet inzwischen und
hier sind 23.800 menschen als verstorben
im rahmen der kurve 19 infektionen
gemeldet worden
das sind in dem fall 11,3 prozent und
das vereinigte königreich haben wir 161
1000 fälle rund und hier ist es so dass
21.700 als offiziell verstorben gemeldet
wurden das ist dann eine prozentzahl von
13,5 prozent und wenn wir das mit
deutschland vergleichen
dann sehen wir dass wir hier heute
159.000 100 fälle offiziell an das
robert-koch-institut von den ländern und
gesundheitsämtern gemeldet bekommen
haben und in deutschland haben wir
momentan 6300 todesfälle offiziell
gemeldet bekommen im rahmen der kurve 19
infektionen
das sind bei uns 4,0 prozent weltweit
wissen wir inzwischen dass rund drei
millionen menschen offiziell als positiv
co at 19 erkannt und gemeldet wurden
also alle länder sind betroffen nahezu
alle länder und wir sehen ein besonders
aktives ausbruchsgeschehen sowie in den
letzten tagen auch in europa und
nordamerika und wie gesagt die ganzen
aktuellen fall sein können sie sehr
detailliert auf den webseiten der
weltgesundheitsorganisation und des
europäischen centers for disease control
finden und auch da jederzeit abrufen
sollte auch täglich aktualisiert sie
alle interessieren aber natürlich vor
allen dingen und zurecht die zahlen in
unserem land in deutschland nochmal den
status 30 der 40 uhr
exakt 100 59.000 119 kurve 19 fälle
übermittelt
das sind 1478 mehr als gestern und
darunter eben 6288 todesfälle
das sind 173 mehr als sie uns gestern
offiziell gemeldet wurden wenn sie sich
zurück erinnern dann haben wir in dieser
woche circa 1000 bis 1500 fälle pro tag
übermittelt bekommen
das ist weniger als in der letzten woche
und das ist eine erfreuliche entwicklung
in der letzten woche hatten wir so immer
rund 2000 fälle am tag aber nach wie vor
haben wir eben jeden tag noch neue fälle
gemeldet wir schätzen aus den uns
vorliegenden informationen dass
inzwischen rund 123.000 519 infiziert
auch wieder genesen sind und die
reproduktion reproduktions zahl wird auf
0,76 geschätzt
das bedeutet dass nach diesen
berechnungen im mittel nun eine saas
kopf zwar infizierte personen weniger
als eine andere ansteckt auch das ist
natürlich eine erfreuliche entwicklung
und wie gesagt lassen sie uns das weiter
beibehalten weil wir diejenigen sind die
dieses virus weiter tragen lassen sie
uns die abstandsregeln und so weiter
einhalten
auch wissen sie dass die daten alle sehr
täglich aktualisiert sind und sie sie
auf unserem dashboard ansehen können
nochmal genau unterschieden nach
landkreisen vielen informationen im
detail ich hier heute nicht darstelle
und sie wissen auch dass wir einen
täglichen situationsbericht verfassen
der ist auch jeden tag natürlich
einsehbar als pdf herunterzuladen und zu
lesen
und dort finden sie weitere
informationen aber ein paar
informationen geben wir ihnen ja auch in
dem pressebriefing jeden tag und das
möchte ich heute auch tun was wissen wir
über die fälle in deutschland
momentan ist das durchschnittsalter der
betroffenen 50 jahre und männer und
frauen sind etwa gleichermaßen
betroffen bei rund vier von fünf der
übermittelten fälle das sind dann auf
die pfalz haben bezogen 129000 und von
denen haben wir klinische informationen
das husten hat die hälfte fieber 42%
schnupfen 21% und ich wie es in den
letzten wochen schon darauf hin dass wir
geschmacks und geruchs verlust offiziell
auch in diese meldungen aufnehmen haben
wir bislang das bei zehn prozent etwa
gemeldet aber das wollte er seit kurzem
erfasst darum fehlen natürlich die daten
über vorherige fälle bei 17 prozent von
allen fällen die uns offiziell gemeldet
werden wurde eine hospitalisierung
übermittelt das heißt also diese
personen werden im krankenhaus oder
wurden im krankenhaus behandelt werden
auch partiell noch im krankenhaus
behandelt und rund 2,7 prozent der uns
übermittelten fälle haben eine
lungenentzündung entwickelt die
todesfälle 6288 personen wie gesagt die
zahl der todesfälle und der anteil der
verstorbenen ist bei uns weiterhin hoch
4 prozent ist die aktuelle berechnung
anhand der offiziell gemeldeten
fallzahlen und das liegt auch daran dass
wir eben immer noch ausbrüche in
altersheimen haben auch im pflegeheim
und auch in krankenhäusern und dort
befinden sich natürlich gerade die mit
menschen die ein besonderes risiko haben
wir haben viele infektionen und
erkrankungsfälle bei älteren menschen
und die todesfälle die jetzt auftreten
betreffen menschen die etwa vor allem
zwei wochen infiziert wurden
das befinden sich immer noch kurvig 19
fälle in der stationären behandlung so
dass er immer noch davon ausgehen müssen
dass weitere menschen versterben werden
und das durchschnittsalter der
verstorbene in deutschland ist momentan
81 jahre
ich möchte heute
unabhängig von diesem statement zwei
punkte noch einmal ansprechen weil sie
von interesse sind denke ich in der
öffentlichkeit aber auch gerade
natürlich in der fachöffentlichkeit es
geht um testen
testkriterien ganz klar ist das ist ja
einer der der wichtigen bausteine einer
einer strategischen bekämpfung dieses
virus das wir tests einsetzen die zum
einen eine hohe aussagekraft haben und
zum anderen natürlich spezifisch in den
jeweiligen situationen eingesetzt werden
wie besser wir testen desto besser
können wir die epidemiologische
situation auch erfassen und bewerten
und es ist sehr erfreulich zu sehen dass
die test kapazitäten schon wieder
gestiegen sind in deutschland und so
hatten wir in der vergangenen woche eine
kapazität von rund 860.000 tests
erreicht
das ist so viel wie wir das noch nie
hatten in deutschland das ist großartig
und nun in der letzten woche wurden auch
viele tests durchgeführt und von rund
467.000 von diesen tests wurden rund
25.000 positiv getestet das sind 5,4
prozent das heißt also die anderen tests
fielen negativ aus und ich denke es ist
auch wichtig zu wissen dass auch manche
personen mehrfach getestet wurden das
heißt diese 467.000 sind nicht 467.000
einzelpersonen unbedingt das ist eine
sehr erfreuliche entwicklung denn ist
zeigt uns dass die tests
niedrigschwellig angewendet werden das
heißt also dass man schneller eine
person kostet als das vielleicht noch
vor einigen wochen der fall war und
meine damen und herren das ist genau das
was wir wünschen und was wir benötigen
wir empfehlen seit mehreren wochen jeder
der akute atemwegserkrankungen getestet
werden
denn die kapazitäten sind da sie sollen
genutzt werden je früher wir eine person
erkennen desto früher können wie sie
behandeln aber desto früher sind wir
natürlich auch in der lage
entsprechend infekt ketten
nachzuvollziehen und diese eben zu
unterbinden durch charakterisierung
isolierung die aufgabe diese große
schwere anspruchsvoll und so wichtige
aufgabe der lokalen gesundheitsämtern
und wir kriegen auch immer wieder die
frage oder wir merken auch dass die
diskussion immer wieder unterwegs ist ob
man auch menschen sollten festen sollte
die keine atemweg symptome haben und das
ist eine wirklich wichtige frage und die
muss man sehr differenziert beantworten
einerseits ist klar wenn wir menschen
ohne symptome testen und das
testergebnis negativ ausfällt dann ist
diese aussage kraft natürlich nicht sehr
hoch der oder diejenige kann ja in der
inkubationszeit sein und kann später
doch noch erkranken dieser test ist ja
eine momentaufnahme
also ein negatives testergebnis muss
nicht große aussagekräftig sein und kann
und das ist ein punkt den wir auch immer
wieder betonen auch zu einer falschen
sicherheit führen deshalb raten wir
weiterhin davon ab generell alle
menschen zu testen aber natürlich ist es
so dass es zumindest ein teil der
infizierten gibt das wissen wir seit
einigen wochen die das virus schon
ausscheiden bevor sie symptome zeigen
also pre symptomatisch wir wissen dass
das ein bis drei tage vor den symptomen
schon auftreten kann
und das heißt also es gibt ganz klar
situationen in denen wir es für sinnvoll
erachten menschen zu testen
auch wenn sie nicht symptomatisch sind
und das ist eben abhängig von der
jeweiligen situation wenn wir zb
infektion so früh wie möglich erkennen
müssen um risikogruppen besser zu
schützen ist es sinnvoll menschen früher
zu testen auch wenn sie gar keine
symptome haben zum beispiel in
bestimmten einrichtungen also in den
einrichtungen wo diese risikogruppen
oder diese besonders gefährdeten mit
menschen untergebracht sind
krankenhäuser pflegeheime altersheim und
so weit kommt ihr da haben und genau
hier an diesen orten wird das prinzip
anlass
bezogen erweitert und das wird gerade
sehr differenziert ausgearbeitet und
bald auch in empfehlungen sich
niederschlag teilweise ist das auch
schon geschehen und das ist ein
kontinuierlicher prozess den wir auch
sehr sorgsam mit vielen fachleuten
abgestimmt ihnen dann zur verfügung
stellen ich möchte die gelegenheit aber
noch mal nutzen um etwas ganz anderes zu
sagen und ich möchte die gelegenheit
nutzen um den laboren in deutschland
sehr herzlich zu danken denn diese sind
es ja die uns überhaupt die fähigkeit
vermitteln diese tests in der güte und
in der menge anzubieten
die deutsche labore sind extrem
leistungsfähig sie leisten
ausgezeichnete arbeit und sie sind und
wie auch die gesundheitsämter ebenfalls
wirklich von ganz zentraler bedeutung
für die ausbruchs bekämpfung und nochmal
meine damen und herren dieses virus ist
in unserem land und wird noch viele
monate in unserem land sein das heißt
weiterhin werden diese einrichtung von
hoher bedeutung sein wir haben wirklich
großes glück in deutschland das sich so
gut aufgestellt sind und darum möchte
ich mich ausdrücklich bei all denen die
dafür sorge tragen sehr sehr herzlich
bedanken
wir tun uns im land einen großen dienst
und unsere ganzen bekämpfungsstrategien
wären ohne diese mitspieler und
mithelfer nicht möglich ein zweiter
aspekt den ich heute ansprechen möchte
ist der von vorsorgeuntersuchungen es
ist wichtig dass natürlich weiter unsere
mitmenschen vorsorgeuntersuchungen
wahrnehmen unter anderem die so
genannten u-untersuchungen die ja gerade
für kinder
säuglinge eine große rolle spielen hier
gibt es auch den faktor der impfungen
der grundimmunisierung für leute die
müssen natürlich zeitgerecht erfolgen
und bei der gelegenheit möchte ich mich
eben deshalb noch mal möchte ich noch
mal klar erwähnen dass diese
untersuchungen gerade diese
untersuchungen unbedingt wahrgenommen
werden sollten
darauf haben auch die bca also die
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung auch der bundesverband der
kinder und jugendärzte noch einmal
hingewiesen
es ist klar dass die praxis abläufe so
eingerichtet sein müssen dass impfungen
ohne ein infektionsrisiko durchgeführt
werden müssen das ist selbstverständlich
und daneben wird auch rechnung getragen
in dem zusammenhang vielleicht auch noch
mal eine klarstellung
es gibt keine hinweise darauf dass sich
eine impfung negativ auf kurven 19 aus
und wie das immunsystem mit einer saß co
wird 252 infektionen umgeht es gibt
keinerlei hinweis dass dort eine
interaktion besteht das sind die akte
das ist der aktuelle kenntnisstand also
wenn man gegen eine andere krankheit
geimpft worden ist und sie kurz darauf
mit saas kauf zwei infizieren wurde dann
kann sich das immunsystem immer noch
genauso gut mit dem saas kauf zwei
auseinandersetzen
es gibt eine stellungnahme der ständigen
impfkommission und die finden sie heute
im epidemische monitor auf unserer
website dort finden sie auch ebenfalls
noch detailliertere hinweise
da ziehen dank wird stehe ich ihnen wie
immer für fragen zur verfügung
vielen dank wir beginnen mit dem ard
hauptstadtstudio vor becker ja ein
großes thema die frage des gestern zb
angekündigt die regeln mit dem
mittelsitz wieder 1 passieren und
stellte eine maske nicht zu setzen
aus ihrer sicht ist das ausreichend ist
das sinnvoll geschützt zu sein gerade
auch mit blick auf längeren gesprächen
das essen muss also leben also ist sehr
wichtig dass der infektionsschutz
gewahrt wird wir uns allen ist klar dass
wir lockerungen haben müssen das
öffentliche leben wieder beleben müssen
und wir wissen dass masken das risiko
senken dass man ein virus auf andere
menschen überträgt und darum ist das
eine sehr sehr wichtige maßnahme
das ist ja auch der grund warum wir seit
längerem masken empfehlen im
öffentlichen raum das bezieht sich ja
gerade auf transportmittel und die
umsetzung in einer pflicht ist ja dann
wiederum eine politische entscheidung
oder eine entscheidung die von den
jeweiligen konzernen von den jeweiligen
arbeitgebern durchgeführt werden masken
senken die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein
virus von einer person auf die andere
übertragen wird aber wir müssen eben
auch die hygieneregeln dabei beachten
das ist wichtig und dafür muss natürlich
weiter gesorgt werden also die masken
pflicht ist hier sicher dann ein mittel
mit dem man die verbreitung des virus
wirklich zum schutze von anderen noch
mal erheblich eindringen einschränken
kann
wir gehen zum heute-journal herr
reichert hat
morgen guten morgen eine frage zu dem
test zu dem er gesagt viel testen wir
testen ist ganz ganz wichtig in
diskussion paisley an wir haben eine
kapazität in helfta fonds würde hätte
wenn ihr haus locken sollen mit denen
getestet wird also die bedingungen unter
denen getestet wird hängt von zwei
dingen ab das hängt zum einen von der
kest kapazität angab das ist ganz klar
das ist ein wichtiger punkt der ja auch
immer mit bedacht wird aber es hängt
natürlich vor allen dingen von der
epidemiologischen situation im land ja
das ist sehr sehr wichtig und wir müssen
quasi wenn wir jetzt an lockerungen
denken dann macht es immer mehr sinn er
früher zu testen als zu spät zu testen
das heißt also wirklich auch personen
die nur leichte symptome haben dass die
immer direkt auch von arzt von ärzten
getestet werden wir haben anekdotisch
gehört in der vergangenheit das
teilweise patienten getestet werden
wollten nicht getestet wurden mit dem
hinweis dass die symptome vielleicht
nicht stark genug wären
das ist ein wichtiger punkt dass man
nochmal ganz ganz deutlich betont je
früher wir testen desto besser
und desto früher können wir insgesamt
infizierte personen erkennen und wir
müssen halt den schutz der wohlhabenden
gruppen auch wenn wir ja auch von anfang
an immer klar im blick hatten in unserem
drei säulen modell der bekämpfung dieser
kurve 19 pandemie dass wir früh testen
dass wir früh ausbrüche erkennen und
menschen früh charakterisieren bzw
in isolation bringen ich bin nicht
dieser auffassung
wir gehen zu dpa forscher haben die
berechnungsgrundlage geändert
drei oder vier tage werk gegangen er
spricht
sie haben das voll erfasst und
offensichtlich ist es mehr in den
letzten tagen nicht gelungen ihn gut
genug zu erklären wie man er berechnet
oder diesen schätzwert berechnen darum
habe ich heute mehr unterstützung
mitgebracht einen unserer hellen köpfe
im institut heran da halten das ist die
person die diesen erwert unter dessen
ägide dieser erwerb berechnet wird und
er wird den das jetzt erklären ok also
zu der frage ganz speziell die
berechnung des erwerbs hat sich nicht
geändert durch diese anpassung es hat
sich nur die darstellung der nordkurve
also der anzahl von geschätzten
neuerkrankungen geändert die haben wir
etwas geglättet
er wehrt berechnung ist aber wie vorher
auch vielen dank
wir gehen zum deutschen ärzteblatt frau
eckert ja das ist es aber wie gesagt
fragen sie doch mal hören andere halten
der ist vergleichbar der wert ist dass
dieselbe methode berechnet worden
also diese dass das sind natürlich
häufig gestellte fragen warum schwankt
der erzzone es ist halt so dass je
niedriger die zahl der geschätzten
neuerkrankungen ist dessen also in der
so kleinere zahlen wir kommen desto mehr
machen sich eben auch lokale cluster
lokale entwicklungen da bemerkbar und
desto mehr kommen wir eben auch in
wallungen rhein wo wir wo wir sozusagen
von tag zu tag auch größere unterschiede
in den eher werten sehen das liegt daran
dass wir eben relativ kurzfristig diese
nährwert auch auch betrachten und
unserer versuchen möglichst aktuell
anlagen am geschehen dran zu sein
der nachteil ist halt das wäre sozusagen
den kleineren zahlen eben auch mehr
schwankungen drin haben
die sollten aber auch nicht jetzt zu
großer beunruhigung führen weil eben
dann diese wackeln geben auch nur einen
kleineren effekt hat es sind ja
sozusagen mal prozentuale änderungen auf
der anzahl von neuerkrankungen und wenn
es eben eine niedrige zahl schon ist
dann ist diese prozentuale änderung eben
auch nur eine kleinere absolute änderung
vielleicht sollten wir noch mal ein
seminar zur berechnung von r machen und
die journalisten die das genau
nachvollziehen und auch teilweise nach
berechnen wir geben ja auch genug
informationen was nahe zu bringen kann
man vielleicht nun mal eine extra stunde
machen
um das zu erklären wenn das gewünscht
ist wir gehen zur reuters herr wackelt
und kurz bevor ich erneute erwartet
freischaltung noch die bitte diejenigen
die ihre fragen gestellt haben wieder
auf das händchen klicken damit sie in
der liste nicht mehr auftauchen erwartet
ja ich habe noch ein paar tage zu testen
sind jetzt zuletzt ja schon deutlich
ausgeweitet testete ja weiter gesteigert
jetzt liegen erste feld ist da nicht an
land und zeigen die gefahr dass der
bisherigen trend erreichbar ist denn
eine psychologisch getestet wird umso
mehr werden auch drei einzel an die
eventuell wieder steigen obwohl es
dessen stehen ja eigentlich ja die gibt
es ja immer mal jeder änderungen die
gemacht wird gibt es immer irritation
aber dafür gibt es am
robert-koch-institut dass diese in diese
daten auswertet und diese dinge ja mit
im kopf hat und auch natürlich
berücksichtigt sie haben vollkommen
recht jedes mal wenn wir test
kapazitäten erhöhen oder erniedrigen hat
das natürlich direkte aussage wetter ist
ja auch der grund warum wir uns die
testung sehr genau anschauen wir schauen
uns auch die raten an der testungen wir
sind ja heute in zum beispiel einem
wesentlich besseren zustand als stumm
vor ich glaube war vor etwa zehn wochen
wir wissen inzwischen ja die anzahl der
tests wir wissen inzwischen auch wie
viele tests gemacht wurden und wie vor
negativ waren das war ja eine zeit lang
lagen uns dieses wissen ja gar nicht vor
das heißt also gerade die rate der
positiven ist sehr sehr wichtig zudem
wissen wir ja auch wo die tests
durchgeführt werden wir können es dazu
ordnung in unserem meldezahlen das heißt
also genau dass diese dynamik haben wir
im blick das ist ja der grund warum wir
uns am institut so intensiv damit
beschäftigen und das führt immer wieder
natürlich auch zu nachfragen von draußen
weil natürlich nicht jeder mensch genau
nachvollziehen kann wie sie zahlen
zusammen hängen aber wie gesagt das ist
ja genau unsere aufgabe das zu
vermitteln
und wir wissen dass wir sind uns dessen
bewusst und es ist natürlich klar wenn
wir jetzt zum beispiel ausbrüche haben
lokale ausbrüche dann wird natürlich in
lokalen geschehen vollzieht die test
rate deutlich größer sein als in einem
allgemeinen geschehen aber genau das
sind die überlegung die wir eben immer
haben und
das ist der job des robert koch
instituts das eben im blick zu haben und
darauf können sie auch verlassen dass
wir das im rahmen der möglichkeiten die
wir haben tun
wir sind jetzt seit zwölf wochen sieben
tage die woche damit beschäftigt wir
sind natürlich auch durchaus an
kapazitätsgrenzen aber sie können
versichert sein dass wir alle mit der
uns zur verfügung stehenden intellekt
und kraft daran arbeiten diese daten so
gut wie möglich auszuwerten und zu
berichten und das tun wir jeden tag in
einer transparenz die sie nicht in jedem
anderen land sehen und das führt
natürlich auch dazu dass jede zahl
hinterfragt wird das ist business für
uns ist nicht immer erfreulich aber so
ist das halt und diese zahlen
publizieren wir systematisch transparent
jeden tag sieben tage die woche
[Musik]
ja ich nehme mir manchmal war das dass
manche denken und sie sagten jetzt
erfolgsrate dass er keine erfolgsraten
und so einfach eine positive rate und
die je weniger geringer die positive
rate ist desto weniger menschen sind ja
wahrscheinlich infiziert wenn wir immer
mehr testen und dann trotzdem weniger
zahlen haben wenn immer mehr menschen
infiziert das heißt was wir hier sehen
ist eigentlich eine positive entwicklung
sie haben in anderen ländern häufig sehr
hohe positiven raten das liegt in den
ländern daran dass dort eben vorwiegend
die schweren fälle getestet werden also
eigentlich sind wir happy wenn wir
niedrigere zahlen haben wir müssen aber
natürlich immer sowohl den nenner als
auch dem zähler im kopf haben ja ich
sehe es als eine positive entwicklung an
wir testen früher wir finden früher
personen die infizierte und das ist
wirklich von überragender wichtigkeit
wenn wir jetzt diese lockerungen
durchführen um das geschehen zu
kontrollieren test kapazität und
ergebnisse sind von
der wichtigkeit wir gehen zur jordaans
mich würde interessieren
das erkennt auch solche daten zusammen
die schon ein schluss war wirklich sehr
ungewöhnliche auswirkungen der
gegenmaßnahmen
auch wir sind der zehn personen leute
haben bei der zahl der verträge bei
herzen wollte diesen gewalt hat sich
schon der erste über sterblichkeit ist
ja wir wir haben das im blick aber die
zahlen die sie angefragt haben die haben
wir noch nicht die gibt es noch nicht in
der detailtiefe dass wir da wirklich
über trends berichten können die aufgabe
des robert koch institut ist es ja auch
das gesundheitsmonitoring durchzuführen
wir sind ja das national public l sind
sie tut das haben wir im blick aber wie
gesagt dazu gibt es noch nicht genügend
zahlen es laufen einige studien von
verschiedenen institutionen
einrichtungen in deutschland die das
zukünftig besser darstellen werden ist
uns bewusst wie gesagt haben wir im
blick
und es ist unheimlich wichtig die zahlen
der über sterblichkeit ja es gibt ja in
deutschland zwei länder hessen und
berlin die diese über sterblichkeit
relativ zeitgenau reportieren der nicht
alle bundesländer tun das für
deutschland insgesamt ist nicht so aber
es wird das im blick gesehen da gibt es
glaube ich ihm kurze oder ich bin mir
sehr sicher in kürze die ersten zahlen
wir sehen dass die über sterblichkeit
steigt in deutschland nicht in einem
sehr hohem maße aber sie steigt und ich
glaube die genauen zahlen werden wir in
kürze erfahren und dann auch mitteilen
in anderen ländern die von kogit 19
betroffen sind steigen die zahlen sehr
stark da nehmen wir die vereinigten
staaten etwa oder italien oder spanien
dort ist das geschehen natürlich auch
größer intensiver wir haben ja auch wenn
ich an die zahl nochmal erinnerungen
darf die ich gerade vorgelesen habe dort
sind ja tatsächlich die kurve fälle die
die die die todeszahlen durch ko wird
deutlich höher
und das passt schon ganz gut zusammen
aber auch in unserem land sieht man sich
die ersten anstiege der über mortalität
exzesse mortalität wie wir das nennen
also das habe ich immer vermutet das ist
eine spekulation die ich noch nicht
belegen kann aber ja wir gehen
eigentlich davon aus dass wahrscheinlich
mehr menschen daran gestorben als sie
offiziell gemeldet sind aber auch dass
das ist eine annahme die ich momentan
habe und zwar aufgrund von den ganzen
komplikationen die man jetzt im laufe
der letzten wochen erfahren hat die
diese infektionskrankheit haben kann
aber die zahlen die richtigen zahlen die
belastbaren werden wir erst in einigen
monaten haben wir gehen zur tagesschau
her car charger ja ich hätte die frage
es gibt meldungen aus der ganzen welt
die wir in den usa hat eine positive
wirkung bei der fertigung auf der zeit
bis zur genesung medikaments geschrieben
wie bewertet die wirksamkeit von rem
lesen wir ist ja eine aufgabe des bfv
also das schwesterinstitut dass ich mit
therapien befasst wir haben bislang die
zahlen die uns zur verfügung stehen die
wir ja von von anderen geliefert
bekommen die machen einen positiven
eindruck aber es sind aus meinem
jetzigen kenntnisstand noch nicht
genügend daten darum hier eine
endgültige aussage zu treffen
vielen dank wir gehen zu der welt herr
holpert ja ich hören sie wie der
unterhalt roma ist heute morgen
programme wie gesagt hatte damit direkt
die länder negativ
die farbe nicht ganz verstand sie sagen
dass man quasi so was wie eine art
immunität pass oder so hätte und nur
wenn man diese ja wenn wir in der lage
sind die immunität wirklich gut zu
bewerten das heißt also das sind wir ja
momentan noch nicht wir haben noch nicht
sehr viele informationen darüber wie gut
eine immunität nach einer überstandenen
kurven 19 krankheit ist wir wissen noch
nicht wie lange sie anhält
wir wissen noch nicht wann sie genau
einsetzt das heißt das sind also noch
eine reihe von unbekannten aber wenn man
den immunität status wirklich
einschätzen kann dann ist das natürlich
eine sehr gute maßnahme zu wissen dass
eine person immun ist der hatten wir
schon mal darüber gesprochen glaube ich
vor zwei wochen hat sie eine ähnliche
frage und ich kann mir schon vorstellen
dass menschen die eine immunität haben
natürlich anders mit diesen menschen
etwas anders umgegangen werden kann sie
anders eingesetzt werden können als
andere menschen aber wie gesagt dazu
fehlen uns einfach noch die daten zur
immunität ich möchte auch noch mal sagen
dass er ist ja auch untersuchungen gibt
zufolge schäden von dieser krankheit die
man auch gar nicht alle absehen können
wir werden sehen wie gut die immunität
von an den personen ist und manche
personen werden vielleicht auch noch
längere folgen haben wo wir dann die
immunität für das leben der menschen
eine eine sekundäre
eine sekundäre eigenschaft ist also hier
sind einfach noch sehr viele fragen
offen
vielen dank beginn zur bild zeitung herr
weiner haben sie alle und ist auf
hinweisen denn die ansteckung derzeit
noch stattfinden konzentriert sich das
infektionsgeschehen der aufschwung die
kliniken oder stimmten sie er in der
vorbereitung aus also wenn wir die die
zahlen die uns zur verfügung stehen
betrachten dann sehen wir dass
tatsächlich die also die heime
krankenhäuser und so einen wichtigen
anteil dabei darstellen und nach wie vor
ist die ansteckungswege der wichtigste
ist die tröpfcheninfektion also von
einer person zur anderen über tröpfchen
und das ist ja ein grund warum neben den
ganzen anderen maßen aber die hände
waschen hände abstand halten
auch dieser bunten nasen bedeckung eine
rolle spielt weil dann diese tröpfchen
einfach nicht so weit fliegen
vielen dank dann gehen wir zum focus
herr meier
eine begründung für die enormen regeln
ein unterschiede der infektionszahlen 24
pro 100000 mecklenburg vorpommern 43 aus
nicht welche gibt es gründe wie maske
oder diana die in streit
[Musik]
reisefreudige weltstadt als neuer tanken
oder so aber geht es da noch die
eingewöhnung
ich denke vor allem an die grenzlage jan
ist eine gute frage die ich ihnen leider
nicht wirklich so richtig erhellend
beantworten kann
also wir wissen folgendes sicher am
anfang dieser pandemie man wir stehen
immer noch am anfang der pandemie aber
am anfang dieser dieser ersten welle die
wir jetzt quasi erleben und und die wir
jetzt gut eingedämmt und runter gedrückt
haben am anfang dieser welle war es so
dass die anzahl der menschen die das
virus in die länder getragen haben
einfach sehr sehr ungleich verteilt war
es waren sehr viele skifahrer also
gesunde mobile menschen die auch viele
kontakte hatten die im berufsleben sehr
intensiv standen die sich viel bewegt
haben also hohe mobilität hatten die
haben das virus gerade in dieser region
baden württemberg und bayern getragen
dass das wissen wir das heißt also die
eintrittsschwellen waren einfach größer
als das in den neuen bundesländern in
den östlichen bundesländern vor allem
gewesen ist das ist sicher das wissen
wir dass das so ist und das hat er
natürlich auch zufolge infektionen
geführt
der zweite aspekt ist der dass wenn wir
uns lokale infektionsgeschehen anschauen
wir wissen das ist natürlich bestimmte
ereignisse gab feste großereignisse wo
dann einfach das virus leichter
übertragen werden kann das erste was uns
allen noch vor augen ist ist die
karnevalsveranstaltung in heinsberg ist
oder ist ja immer noch den westfalen und
dort war es eben eine größere
veranstaltung und wir wissen dass solche
veranstaltung eben auch in bayern
unterwegs waren türken heute wird immer
wieder hier erwähnt es gibt momentan
eine hypothese die aber noch einfach
eine hypothese ist noch eine
arbeitshypothese
wir wissen das
es gibt eine hypothese dass die impfung
gegen bcg über einen epigenetischen
effekt dazu führt dass länger man eine
immunität hat eine generelle immunität
stärker gegen bestimmte
infektionskrankheiten hat diese
hypothese wird von manchen
wissenschaftlern in den ring geworfen
sie ist nicht belegt sie wird wir wissen
noch nicht genau wie wir sie wirklich
überprüfen können dass es auch wenn wir
eine hypothese wäre schön wenn das so
wäre das wird sich vielleicht in der
zukunft zeigen
und der dritte aspekt der ist sicher der
dass natürlich einfach die die struktur
der länder ist an dass der bundesländer
wir haben natürlich in ländern eine
höhere dichte
also eine höhere besiedlungsdichte und
wir haben größere städte und das heißt
also dadurch ist einfach die chance dass
ein mensch einen anderen ansteck
natürlich größer als in den
flächenländern die nicht so eine dichte
besiedlung haben das sind die hypothesen
die wir bislang haben also das erste ist
klar dieser eintrag gerade von
skifahrern war ein großer aspekt und die
veranstaltung ist sicher ein großer
aspekt und das andere sind plausibel
hypothesen mit ausnahme dieser hypothese
dass die immunität durch bgm funk
vielleicht höher wäre
das ist eine reine hypothese aber die
plausibilität der der dichte von
personen in bestimmten regionen ist
halte ich auch für sehr hoch na ja das
kann man insofern überprüfen als dass
man die die immunität der person
überprüfen würde wir haben wir keine
spezifische immunität bislang gegen
korona virus gefunden in das ist ein
virus was wir noch nicht gesehen haben
was man inzwischen weiß ist allerdings
das sind erste untersuchungen die von
einer berliner federführend von der
berliner arbeitsgruppe ort durchgeführt
wird
das ist offensichtlich bei manchen
personen auch bei kinder und einen
gewissen anteil bestimmte immunzellen
sogenannte t zellen also haben wir zwei
aber der immunität ist eine sind die die
humorale immunität die die also
antikörper vermittelt ist das andere ist
die zelluläre die sg zu vermitteln dass
es offensichtlich bestimmte so
population von t zellen gibt die schon
mal so ein also die
dieses virus zumindest erkennen ob sie
eine wirkung haben weiß man nicht das
sind untersuchungen die immer weiter
fortschreiten und wo man dann vielleicht
erkenntnisse gewinnt auf treuer wir
gehen zu mtv hits sie sagten ich dachte
schon weiterhin gesagt das ganze ist
kein sprinter hatten auch jetzt hatte
ich schon sagen jeder der ein bisschen
geld an ge vielleicht ins ziel kommt als
ausblick tatsächlich nächsten also die
frage kann ich nicht beantworten aber
ich weiß nur dass wir am anfang dieses
marathons sind ich habe diese dieses
wort ebenfalls vor
ich weiß gar nicht ob vor drei monaten
oder so hier im institut benutzt weil es
ja auch weil klar war dass das das eben
eine pandemie ist die eine bevölkerung
trifft die eben keine immunität hat so
eine pandemie gehen erst vorbei wenn
rund 60 bis 70 prozent der bevölkerung
durchsetzt sind dann ist die chance
gegeben dieses virus einzudämmen
wir haben vielleicht also einen
einstelligen prozentsatz nach unseren
jetzt in allen folgen daten hat sich
vielleicht in deutschland infiziert das
ist es immer klar das ist ein marathon
ist aber wir wissen eben nicht wie viel
zeit es dauert bis dieser marathon zu
ende ist das ist das was wir als eine
erste welle bezeichnen die mehrheit der
wissenschaftler geht davon aus dass es
zu einer zweiten welle kommt vielleicht
sogar zu einer dritten es gibt auch
viele wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen die denken dass
gerade der herbst natürlich eine zeit
ist wo das sein kann und wir werden das
sehen aber das ist klar dieses virus ist
in unserem landes wird noch monatelang
in unserem land sein
darum müssen wir monatelang in dieser so
genannten neuen normalität leben wo wir
dafür sorge tragen müssen dass das virus
möglichst wenig chancen hat sich heute
auszubreiten und das wird so lange nach
der jetzigen sicht der dinge so lange
sein bis wir
entweder einen impfstoff haben der uns
dann eine nötige immunität verleiht wenn
wir dann geimpften und einen guten
impfstoff haben oder wenn wir bessere
medikamente haben mit denen wir besser
schneller
die infizierten behandeln können oder
wenn es uns gelingt und welche ganz
genialen konzepte zu entwickeln die
bislang aber leider nicht da sind wie
wir diese physische distanzierung
vielleicht auch mit irgendwelchen
kreativen tools anders auf die reihe
kriegen aber da habe ich bislang noch
keine ideen gesehen die überzeugend
waren und uns physikalisch vor den
tröpfchen infektion anders schützen als
zurzeit mit masken die wir darum mir
auch einsetzen also die der optimismus
ist schon groß dass für medikamente
haben werden die helfen und natürlich
gibt es auch eine menge optimismus dass
ein impfstoff geben wird aber unabhängig
davon ist eine sache ziemlich klar
diese diese idee dass man dieses virus
sozusagen ära die ziert also das heißt
ausrottet aus der aus der menschlichen
population man muss das ja dann weltweit
machen dieses dieses szenario wird ohne
einen impfstoff nicht gelingen wollen
sie noch was zu herdenimmunität sagen
das ist vielleicht ein missverständnis
wir wollen natürlich nicht warten bis
alle ja okay also also herdenimmunität
heißt ja dass rund 60 bis 70 prozent der
bevölkerung infiziert sind und wie
gesagt dieses szenario können wir uns
nicht vorstellen weil dabei eben einfach
sehr sehr viele menschen sterben werden
ist es gab ja modellierungen die auch
immer noch natürlich
gelten wenn dieses virus sich einfach
durch die bevölkerung durchgehen würde
ohne das irgendwie aufgehalten wird und
dann haben wir ja da gibt es modelle wo
dann von hohen todesraten gesprochen
wird
darum wollen wir das natürlich
verhindern darum müssen wir das virus
immer einfach eindämmen hast diesen
langen weg haben wir vor uns denn mit
ihm möglichst nicht zu viele menschen
infiziert werden und nicht zu viele
menschen ist krankenhaus kommen nicht so
viele menschen sterben
und das ist unser ziel diese
infektionsrate schlacht zu halten
wir gehen zum südwestrundfunk herr
kümmerer verändert oder den gästen
inflationsbericht steht dazu dass er
jetzt aus zwei zahlen berechnet wird in
teilen neu erkannten geteilt durch die
zahl der erkannten vor vier tagen ist
das modell tatsächlich jetzt so stark
vereinfacht also wie gesagt ist die
berechnung von er ist nicht verändert
worden ich bitte das auch nicht zu sagen
weil es einfach nicht stimmt und immer
wieder für verwirrung sorgt also ich
glaube wirklich wir sollten wir eine
seminar machen
andere halten und alle die journalisten
die das genau verstehen wollen
vielleicht kann man das wohl mal
bilateral klären aber gerne wenn sie
noch mal sagen herr andere halten so
genau ich glaube das ist einfach
vielleicht auch eine missverständliche
formulierung die wir gewählt haben also
die berechnung von er hat sich nicht
geändert
es ist nur so dass wir eben die
darstellung dieser neue casting kurve
etwas mit etwas mehr glättung jetzt
machen und das führt dazu dass ich diese
rettung die auch in der berechnung von
er im prinzip einen zwischenschritt
darstellt dass ich darüber so zu sagen
jetzt leichter dass er berechnet könnte
indem ich die glättung ausnutze dafür
das führt aber nicht zu anderen
ergebnissen das führt zu den gleichen
ergebnissen hat sich nicht geändert
beim letzten mal hatte ich weiß gar
nicht ob sie das war eine kümmern jemand
hatte er das selber ausgerechnet und
offensichtlich war der von teilweise
anderen bedingungen ausgegangen als als
es der wirklichkeit entspricht und darum
glaube ich weiß wirklich gut wenn man
noch mal im hinterzimmer blumen
erbrechen also die berechnungsmethode
von r wurde nicht geändert
wir gehen zur taz herr kraus fällt kurz
aus papier tageswerten also aus den
letzten acht tagen danach bleibt es im
rechten ist aus dem produzenten von zwei
werden also lebt am letzten sonntag aber
diese tageswerte werden wir jetzt als
durch einen von vier tage berechnet wenn
ich es nicht verstehe ist dass das alte
haus kommt ich kann es noch nicht ganz
nachvollziehen über die gruppe hat sich
die gruppe genau passt der grundlegend
verändert wird die neue methode da war
bisher die u23 jetzt geht das konzept
nicht runter und so ändern dass es
formation bei den leuten gespielt hat
und ich habe zehn haben oder ich das
spiel verlieren wir sie haben nicht die
berechnung die ausgangswerte also ich
würde wirklich sagen also das ist das
ist ja ein pressebriefing kann hat
mathematik seminar noch ich ich würde
ihn wirklich sagen ich fänd's gut wenn
sie sich direkt
wir werden das einrichten dass sie sich
bilateral vielleicht der ganzen klub der
interessierten miteinander vernetzt und
dann klären wo das noch mal ja
wie das ok
vielen dank wir kommen zu dem
niederländischen rundfunk juli fanden
hülsbeck vorfand ins bett guten tag herr
wieder hören wir ja wieder
ich habe eine wiedereröffnung der schule
in den niederlande sind in einer woche
die grundschule und geht als erste dran
die juwi uhr kinder gebannt vor
da unsere unseres rpc leben davon
ausgehen dass in teilen der große rolle
spiele in die verbreitung des virus in
deutschland würde ich ganz andere töne
der herr droste
das bedeutet aus studien hin wie
signalisieren das geht natürlich eine
genau so anstellen sind als erwachsene
ja wir wissen über kinder noch nicht
sehr viel die ganzen daten die uns
vorliegen sagen aber natürlich dass
kinder auch angesteckt werden können das
wissen wir ja schon sehr lange die
ersten daten die dazu publiziert wurden
stammen ja aus china und in china war zu
der zeit als die dort publiziert wurden
die schulen ja zu so dass man also die
bedeutung der kinder für die
weiterverbreitung nicht sehr gut
einschätzen konnte es gab es viele
haushalts studien hauptsächlich weil er
dort sehr früh ein shutdown durchgeführt
wurde
wir also der wissenstand ist der dass
die kinder angesteckt werden können
der wissensstand ist der dass kinder das
virus ausscheiden können und das heißt
also auch kinder können natürlich auch
andere menschen anstecken und der
wissensstand ist der dass kinder in der
regel nicht so schwer erkrankten
beziehungsweise insgesamt weniger
symptome zeigen das heißt von 100
erkrankten kindern zeigen eben weniger
die symptome als es bei erwachsenen der
fall sind die älter die menschen werden
desto stärker ist dann die chance dass
man ausgeprägte symptome zahlt insofern
spielen kinder für die verbreitung nach
der jetzt sind nach dem jetzigen
kenntnisstand dieselbe rolle wie das
vielleicht erwachsene sind oder gesunde
erwachsene oder ältere dass das ist der
der aktuelle kenntnisstand dass sie eine
größere oder geringe rolle spielt ist
nicht klar
aber was natürlich klar ist dass kinder
aufgrund ihres sozialverhaltens
natürlich vielleicht dann schneller
andere menschen anstecken können weil
sie sich eben nicht so gut an die an die
regeln halten die ja so wichtig sind
diese abstandsregel und die
hygieneregeln
na ja also ich denke das entscheidende
ist das dahinterliegende hygiene konzept
ja das ist ja das was uns alle sehr
bewegt und was natürlich alle branchen
oder alle bereiche wenn wir lockerungen
durchführen in hohem maße bewegt wie
führen wir hygiene konzepte durch ich
meine 1 ist ja klar wir wollen das
öffentliche leben wieder beleben die
belastung
der der eltern ist natürlich auch groß
ist gar keine frage dass kinder auch
wieder auf grund von vielen live auf
aufgrund vieler umstände wieder in
schulen gehen müssen und sollten und es
ist hier vor allen dingen wichtig wie
hier mit konzepten umgegangen wird da
werden einige konzept entwickelt und ich
bin mir sicher dass da sehr sehr gute
konzepte weltweit entwickelt werden und
hier ist es vor allem wichtig dass diese
konzepte wirklich dass die wirklich
ausgetauscht werden und man best
practice konzepte hat und der zweite
aspekt und da sind wichtiger punkt egal
ob wir jetzt in deutschland und holland
sind hier muss natürlich sehr intensiv
aufgepasst werden dass infektion sehr
schnell erkannt werden und da sind wir
zum beispiel wieder bei dem thema das
wir eben angesprochen haben das thema
des testens also auch hier muss man
gerade sehr niedrigschwellig testen um
dann mögliche infektionen rasch zu
erkennen und den inflationsausblick zu
unterbinden und denke diese diese
rahmenbedingungen die sind ganz
entscheidend wir gehen zu bloomberg tv
frau christa also zu zweit kann ihnen
sagen dass wir die ersten ergebnisse im
mai haben werden das sind aber
vorläufige ergebnisse und die werden
natürlich im entsprechenden kontext
darstellen das heißt also wirklich dass
sie auch interpretationsfähig sind daher
sind vor allem die studien die wir mit
den blutspendediensten durchführen wo
wir ja in einigen blutspendediensten
antikörper nachweisen um da zu sehen
wieviel antikörper sind und das ergebnis
wird auch erst dann vorgestellt wenn wir
wissen wie das zu berechnen ist im app
ideologischen hintergrund und auch unter
einbeziehung natürlich der testmethode
denn jede testmethode hat einen
bestimmten grund bestimmte spezifität
und sensitivität
das heißt diese daten müssen erst
wirklich geglättet werden und
statistisch evaluiert werden die erste
frage die labore es gibt ja große labor
verbünde und es ist eigentlich immer
möglich gewesen dass natürlich auch
labore aus bestimmten ländern in
deutschen laboren untersucht werden
genauso wie bestimmte proben von
deutschland auch in anderen laboren
untersucht werden es gibt ja große labor
verbünde die teilweise weit über ein
land hinaus gehen insofern ist diese
diese möglichkeit natürlich gegeben
also es gibt keine rechtliche grundlage
dass das nicht so wäre ja wir gehen zu
herrn wertvoll wenn sie noch ihre
redaktion bitte einen 11 uhr und was
meinen sie wenn er in uns was ich habe
sie nicht verstanden da waren die
akustisch nicht mehr zu vernehmen
wie haben sie
stellen sie ihre frage bitte kann ich
ihnen nicht sagen würde ich auch gerne
selber wissen ist es tut mir leid
könnten entweder größere veranstaltungen
als reicht wie feste oder auf 62 jahre
nach diesem termin also wie gesagt das
ist wie gesagt wie das schon mehrfach
klar gestellt wurde
größere veranstaltungen sind natürlich
epidemiologisch schwierig ganz klar weil
eben die chance dass wir in sich
vorbereiten dort hoch ist wenn dort
infizierte person sind um die
entscheidung von dieser veranstaltung
wieder zugelassen sind treffen
politischer entscheidungsträger
wir gehen zu radio münchen frau schmidt
nachdenken
[Musik]
umgekehrt das ist naiv sei eben gerade
auf eine impfung war
wenn ich das richtig verstehe geht es
bei diesem tanz um die frage der dauer
der immunität anfrage jetzt an sie wie
kann denn die immunität durch einen
impfstoff für längere zeit gewährleistet
werden als bei natürlichen immunität
es ist wieder unabhängig davon ob dieses
virus saisonal notiert andere ihre
dieser also ich habe nicht gesagt dass
immunität naiv ist dann möchte ich sie
korrigieren muss ich leider korrigieren
sondern ich habe gesagt der gedanke dass
wir quasi das virus durch die population
laufen lassen damit für eine natürliche
eine so genannte herdenimmunität
erreichen dieser gedanke ist naiv wenn
wir das virus nicht kontrollieren können
weil wir dann eben viele und zwar nach
den berechnungen von modellen die
verschiedene wissenschaftler
durchgeführt haben viele hunderttausend
tote haben wurden in unserem land das
heißt also das ist der grund warum eine
das erreichen einer herdenimmunität mit
diesem virus nicht das ziel sein kann
das haben wir in anderen ländern gesehen
dass das nicht funktioniert denn dieses
virus ist ein virus das eine hohe
krankheitslast hat das ist ein virus das
zu schweren krankheitserscheinungen
führt und auch wahrscheinlich bei vielen
patienten auch zu folgeschäden
wenn man diese infektionskrankheit
überstanden hat und eine immunität
ausbildet dann wissen wir auch zur zeit
noch nicht wie gut diese immunität sein
wird und von daher kann ich diese frage
von ihnen ob der impfstoff eine bessere
immunität bringen wird wie ein
natürlicher inflation nicht einfacher
aber eins ist klar wenn ein impfstoff
effektiv und sicher ist dann werden an
diesem impfstoff eben nicht annähernd so
viele menschen werden sterben wenn sie
geimpft sind und damit dem virus
infiziert werden als wenn sie natürlich
infiziert werden
dieses virus hat eine reihe von
eigenschaften die ich niemandem
aussetzen möchte weder mir selber und
auch nicht meinen kindern um das ganz
deutlich zu sagen und wer das tut und
denkt dass er damit eine herdenimmunität
hervorruft ist naiv oder er hat
vielleicht auch irgendwelche anderen
dinge im kopf aber der gesundheit der
menschen die dieser person anvertraut
sind kann nicht in seinem sinne sein das
möchte ich ganz deutlich sagen dieses
virus hat inzwischen weltweit wirklich
viele menschen getötet haben 3 millionen
fälle bereits und da sind ja nur die
fälle die offiziell gemeldet wird
insofern ist das meine antwort darauf
ich kann sie nur alle warnen nicht mit
diesem virus zulässig umzugehen ist zu
unterschätzen
und solange wir keinen impfstoff haben
wird dieses virus leider in der
population sein und mit den für immer
gearteten gefahren umgehen wie das virus
wie das virus mutiert ist eine frage die
sie noch stellen
wir haben ja schon relativ viele
informationen über mutationen das sind
mutationen die bislang nach einschätzung
der mehrheit der wissenschaftler nicht
dazu geführt haben dass das virus sich
biologisch verändert hat wissen wir aber
noch nicht genau
wir wissen aber sicher dass die korona
während sich nicht in dem maße genetisch
verändern wie das zum beispiel bei
influenza viren der fall ist
und bei diesen influenza viren haben wir
sehr große sehr große veränderungen im
genom und das ist eines der großen
herausforderung für die
impfstoffentwicklung da diese während
sich so stark immer verändern sie
tauschen teilweise wirklich große stücke
ihres gesamten erbgutes aus und erlangen
dadurch wirklich ganz neue biologische
eigenschaften das ist bei corona während
so nicht bekannt
wir haben jetzt noch zwei fragen bitte
um kurze frage und auch kurze antwort
plant interview herr bohren
vielen dank endlich einmal zur schule
geht hast unsere daten lagen dort fahren
wir jetzt dass die datenlage zur
anstellung gefahr von kindern sehr
widersprüchlich ist bisher die
empfehlung die kita ist entspannung zu
schließen am anfang ein analog schluss
gewesen sei tatsächlich ist die frage
warum hat man nicht schon oder kind hast
vor der schließung ich sage mal
exemplarisch ein paar schulen oder kitas
durch getestet und werden heute
exemplarisch jetzt bei geöffneten
schulen daten erhoben sozusagen schwul
deckende tests durch gute frage
hinterher ist man immer schlauer
da hätte man tatsächlich
im nachhinein wäre das eine gute idee
gewesen aber tatsächlich werden momentan
solche studien geplant und die werden
auch durchgeführt werde wir brauchen ja
bessere daten
es gibt eine studie die in england
durchgeführt wurde die die dass daten
die werden jetzt in kürze publiziert die
uns ein bisschen mehr hinweise geben
aber was wirklich wichtig ist diese
studien müssten immer genau analysiert
werden vor welchem hintergrund wohnen
sie erhoben was war das epidemiologische
setting wie groß ist die aussage gehofft
es ist wichtig dass die menschen sich
nicht immer nur auf die prozentzahlen
konzentrieren sondern auch die
jeweiligen vor und nachteile der studie
wirklich herausarbeiten und das wenn man
das zusammen fasst dann ist der
wissensstand eben noch nicht groß genug
die letzte frage von aepoc times voraus
[Musik]
na ja es geht immer um abwägen des
schutts gutes das ist ja klar also zum
einen machen wir als robert
koch-institut eben generelle
empfehlungen und diese generelle
empfehlungen werden ja dann auf lokaler
ebene umgesetzt und es ist glaube ich
jeden nachvollziehbar wenn eine person
zum beispiel eine chronisch kranke
atem weg seine copd hat dass diese
person unter diesem atemschutz so stark
leiden würde das ihre gesundheit leidet
dann ist ja klar dass der jeweilige arzt
sich entscheiden muss welchen weg er
geht und das ist und bleibt doch immer
die entscheidung des arztes was das ist
wichtig so her weil natürlich nur der
arzt einschätzen kann wie es der person
geht und wie gut sie mit einer solchen
artenschutz oder bedeckung umgehen kann
was was dazu kommt sind eben schlaue
konzept das ist ja auch das was wir
vorher schlau konzepte wie man sich vor
diesen infektionen schützen kann und
sollte plexiglasscheiben sind zum
beispiel eine gute idee die sieht man
immer häufiger jetzt und sie sind eben
tatsächlich in der lage
tröpfcheninfektionen zu unterbinden und
insofern sind das gute konzept und wir
brauchen mehr von diesen guten konzepten
die lokal daneben auch umgesetzt werden
müssen und noch mal mein appell ist hier
auch dass man diese konzepte wirklich
austausch damit möglichst viele menschen
davon profitieren
vielen dank dann sind wir am ende
angekommen wir sehen uns dienstag und
mal gucken ob er bis dahin das erste
seminar organisiert bekommen haben
vielen dank danke ihnen
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen feiertag
und vor allen dingen grüße ich hier die
polizistinnen und polizisten die
hundertschaften die endlich mal den
ersten mal zu hause verbringen können
danke